and now that Bachelorette Rachael is
done with Peter - Peter be the one to
fill the role well we haven't heard the
last from him because today he's going
published his first under breakup where
after the breakup there was no
conversation it was cold turkey right
than in there 31 year old Peter is
speaking out for the first time since
that's super awkward reunion with Rachel
I'm shaking like a leaf right now
hydrants done terrified Peter who was in
tears while watching the break-up
backstage know this he almost walked out
and skipped going onstage my field time
it's been three months since Rachel
dumped him when he confessed he wasn't
ready to propose and Peter admits he's
still getting over it she's an obviously
a very happy place I'm getting to a
happy place so does that happy place
include being The Bachelor we were first
asked him about that possibility back in
April during the group date I say this
doesn't work out would you be the
bachelor right now to be really honest
Rachel 7 I focus but now sounds as if
he's open to it I'd have to think a lot
about it and he may be destined to do it
the handsome fan favorite did list
Beyond The Bachelor other future plans
in his high-school yearbook back in 2005
but at the time I had not had a serious
girlfriend I don't even think I'd kissed
a girl at that point and the bass were
just are airing this man was like the
epitome of what every guy want to be he
was known by all and does
the girls and I wanted the girls Wow
well maybe his ambition will come true
because a lot of people would love to
see Peter be the next Bachelor but what
about Dean that's the possibility too
since the 26 year old is on paradise
this season and Chris Harrison told us
well they're waiting to see what happens
on that show before making the official
bachelor announcement